so i want to talk about this next
segment but i do uh want to i want to
give you guys an update so last night we
had marjorie taylor green on the show
she was absolutely fantastic and one of
the things that came up was dan crenshaw
being listed by the world economic
forum's young uh was it young global
leaders thing yeah what pete buddha
judge and tulsi gabbard buddhijus was a
different year so i actually uh reached
out to dan crenshaw and he i'll give you
the gist of of his statement paraphrase
basically
his understanding or i should say my
takeaway from what he said is that this
is an editorial list here that they have
nothing to do with it's like uh so i
asked him is this like forbes 30 under
30 like the world economic forum just
decides these are people we think you
should watch and he was like yes there
was no communication involved they just
put me on some list
and now he's like people see that and
they think i'm associated in some way i
i think it's important that you know
people hear his response because we did
pull that up and i even said i don't
know what this young global leaders
thing is
and if it turns out that the davos group
just like makes a list of people they're
interested in whether you realize it or
not i don't want to smear the guy over
something someone else does and i agree
with you but why would they pick him
right yeah i mean
there's god they're not
they're not going to pick marjory green
they're not going to pick certain people
so why did they pick you and i'm telling
you what man my wife cannot stand him
you know and she just think that he is a
part of the establishment i remember and
i and i can't verify that unequivocally
i remember when he first came out and i
said yeah i like this dude military guy
he's bad to the bone missing the eye
this is the dude and then he started
it's like they get in office and they
start getting softer and softer and
softer and before you know it they're
acquiescing in this way they're they're
trying to be cool with these people and
they're in the middle they're not like
marjorie green like i'm not expecting
anybody to be radical but i'm expecting
you to go in there and tear stuff up i'm
expecting you to go in there and stand
your ground and stand on the principles
that people are asking you to stand on
you got elected because you had these
campaign videos of you being outside of
coming in and serving your community and
because you were you were in you know in
the military but then you get in there
and you just shrink down
and and you just like to everybody else
and and it's easy for me to talk because
i'm not in politics but like
is that what happens to you when you get
in the podcast the ones that want
marjorie taylor green yeah she's not you
know how long is amazing and i love her
i met her before she ever was in
politics and i remember
at some conference and she was like i'ma
run for office and i remember you know
she was such a cool person in the
fitness and but like how long is she
going to last
i'll tell you she does shows like this
for a long time i'll tell you around i
hope so i hope she
the big thing for me was it's all about
the media they're they're you know she's
she said you know cookie things on
facebook back in the day she apologized
for those things i don't i don't know if
i agree with her on all of her policy
positions but when she said she went
down to congress and forced roll call
votes to make all the members actually
come down and have to vote on these
bills i was just like that deserves a
standing ovation absolutely making these
people do their jobs and i got messages
from people where they were like as soon
as i heard that i was like i'll vote for
cause like all of her policy positions
aside if she's going there and telling
all these members of congress get down
here vote and do your jobs
i'll take it and show the constituents
what you're voting for because otherwise
that would be hidden from them so
holding them account to the point where
even republicans are mad at her and
democrats are mad at her because they
can't just pass through all these bills
really fast i think that's great i think
the the more we have
you know the stagnation in government
the better government we have that's my
own personal perspective that's how i
see it because when they're arguing and
fighting amongst each other they're not
trying to put government on someone else
and they've been put in a lot of
government on a lot of people and she's
stopping it somewhat but i think she i
think she's a great example for all
americans
that if you feel the call to serve you
don't have to be some politician you
don't have to have some legacy of
political a political background and
that's true for afc as well i want to be
i want to do this because i feel like i
want to make a difference and if you
pursue it because i remember her saying
she was going to do it before she ever
did it and she pursued it and she won
and and and i think you're correct about
alc even though i think she's dumber
than a bag of rocks
um well i i don't i don't know let me
know
that's not fair to the background
let me not disrespect rocks like that
you know
angry right now you ain't triggered
anger
ancient rocks i'm not gonna disrespect
them like that so let me not be
superfluous
i think that her arguments are poor
i think that she believes what she's
saying though and that's why she's been
so successful i i i honestly believe
that
afc i disagree man you don't think she i
think she's dumb enough to believe every
time they come out and they say like hey
aoc i'm criticizing you for this thing
you did she goes you just want to date
me
i think she's dumb enough to believe
that
she think people want to sleep with her
you know
um my i i don't like
you know we we make fun of her for being
dom and all that stuff i'm actually not
a fan of doing that i don't like her i i
do think she is lacking in inability i
think she's a master of marketing she's
a master of media manipulation
but uh
i i you know i don't know i wanna i
wanna make sure that we when we when we
when we present criticisms it's
substantive
and i agree i agree greasy yeah
sometimes we you know sometimes i go
over the top and i may say certain words
because that's how i really feel but in
in actuality you have to say look at the
critique of what she's doing she
literally came on television and bashed
people for not wearing masks she bashed
them she'd been bashing desantis
and she's literally in his state
drinking and having a good time hugging
people kissing and partying that's only
what we saw on camera she was probably
living her best life but she get on tv
and she make these claims she talks
about climate change oh we're gonna all
die in 13 years or something it's
irreversible
but i guarantee you she got on a jet a
plane and flew to miami rented a car
probably and is driving around living
her best life these people
they're either dumb or they're evil
that's one of the two and i think it's
an evil dude it could be both and i'm
not trying to be superfluous in the in
my description of her i just really do
think that these people are
evil or they are
completely out of there they're not
ignorant because they think climate
change is not going to be stopped
they're ignorant because it can be we
can withdraw the carbon from the
atmosphere
it's got to be evil and i'll tell you
why didn't obama buy beachfront property
yeah of course he did the banks are
giving him loans 24. so here's so that
bill gates
so these people that come out and claim
all this stuff climate change and
whatever
they do the opposite when i see marjory
taylor green refusing to wear a mask and
she know and she's got i think she was
saying like you know ninety thousand
five thousand fines or something accrued
from all the stupid bs she's going down
to the house and nancy below she's like
everybody gotta wear mask and she's not
gonna do it that's consistent with what
she said she's doing what she says right
when aoc says texas is you know
effectively going to killing people by
ending the mass mandates and then she
chooses not to wear a mask in florida
but criticizes desantis you can see how
she really feels when no one tells her
she has to she won't so it's not about
wearing the masks it's about the
government mandating people do it yeah
so it's like well i think it's evil too
because it's like you know
the position
and the facts but you present something
different to the people
because you want to toe the line because
you want to get reelected why would you
do people like that when you don't
practice what you preach let's put it
this way
no matter what no matter which direction
you go it's evil here's why
if she thinks masks
really will save lives and then you have
to have them
then she goes to part and parties
without one thinking she'll be killing
people by doing that that's kind of evil
that sounds evil yeah willfully putting
people at risk at least based on that
belief that masks are important or she's
claiming masks are important and doesn't
actually believe it and is just lying to
toe some tribal line
also evil dude
it's a career move right these people
this is what i'm learning about politics
these people want to stay in office as
long as they can because when you're in
office it's not just your little salary
you get you know 170 thousand dollars
you get in the house representatives
every two years or whatever i mean you
know you got a 1.4 million dollar budget
right so per year i think it is but you
know how many butts they kissing and how
many people they doing deals with behind
the scenes you staying there long enough
you're gonna be you're gonna be set for
the rest of your life and i often wonder
is this what they're really doing it for
is she doing this to secure the bag for
the rest of her life
pointing out lies that she know aren't
true but she have to push those to get
reelected because she really don't care
i mean she don't care about other people
she it doesn't appear that she does i
don't know this crazy data like this cnn
analyst saying that masks are facial
calling them facial decorations on tv
like this is leanna wen said this two
weeks ago like so how can you see on cnn
cnn so how confusing for someone to be
like you're supposed to wear a mask but
then the cnn guidance comes out or the
analyst and says
they're not they don't function
processes this is your issue
it's it's almost like um you know people
bring up yuri besmanov all the time just
confuse and demoralize the population
keep them in a constant state of chaos
so they can't figure out what's going on
what they're supposed to do
and the politicians are also in that
state so well let's go we'll go back to
how she ended up being brought up we're
talking about you know first it was dan
crenshaw you know he's he's arguing with
marjorie taylor green
you know we we had uh we had mtg on and
i think the member segment we did with
her it was getting it was getting legit
and i'm like man i really want to have
like a longer form off youtube so we can
just go deep dive on a bunch of topics
because when we do the youtube show it's
very topical it's very direct topical we
mostly talked about her and censorship
and and congress and what was going on
in congress and then i we started
getting to the nitty gritty of just like
the thing she's talked about in the past
how she feels how she feels about
vaccine mandates and it was raw and it
was real and then i was just like man
she was swearing and i'm like it did not
feel like the other politicians we've
had on the show who are worried about
offending one side or the other and
trying to get votes it felt like she was
just like i'm here and i'm gonna tell
you what i think and i was like man
that's that's what people like about
trump yes that's what people like about
mtg you know we're so sick of the
inauthentic fake bs in politics we will
take something that seems genuine and
unfortunately for the populist left the
people they brought on they're all just
disingenuous well let's be honest aoc
talks a big game but when pelosi says
step in line she steps in line and votes
like pelosi wants her to vote but she
also mastered social media and she also
mastered the way of engaging with people
and exploiting that to its fullest
extent and there are algorithms that of
course are pushing her messaging out to
millions and millions of people in an
unrestricted way which of course is
something that the other side does not
have so when you have direct lines
through the algorithm to the youth
you're able to influence them especially
when you set up a gaming channel i mean
this person i don't think she's dumb i
think she's very smart i think she's
very very calculated it might have been
a mistake that she got caught without
you know wearing a mask in florida uh
ron desantis said that this is quote uh
a ruling class mentality and i think
that has more kind of perspective to it
but but look what she did with with
january 6th look how she involved
herself in that event she lied when she
lied about being at the capitol no no so
yeah i i when this story came out aoc
claimed that she thought the writers
admitted to her her office she made that
up the timeline made no sense i saw ben
shapiro tweeting it and i tweeted him
like yo it's not it's not that she's you
know making up the fear it's that the
whole story is fabricated i couldn't
believe how many people on the right
didn't catch this
when the cop knocks on her door and aoc
is like so then i'm like i'm in i hide
in the bathroom and i'm thinking like
they found me or whatever and then i
hear where is she and it's the most
exaggerated insanity ever and then she's
thinking she was going to die or
whatever she said when i saw that story
i was like wait
you know i actually argued the
huffington post guy in through direct
messages because because i said you know
when she came out in the hallway there
were already a bunch of people there
being evacuated so where was she she
wasn't in the capital she was in her
building then people said yeah but the
capital does connect through tunnels to
that building and then i was like why
when did the rioters make it to the
tunnels they didn't did they think they
were gonna why do they think that and
then
i i actually went through the timeline
of when she said it was this time it was
like one o'clock when she was getting
her food and she had a knock on the door
and i went at one o'clock not a single
rioter had even made it to the building
yet
it was it was they had just breached the
first barricade
no one knew what had happened and the
police it was that famous video where
the cops fanning people in
there it wasn't until i think an hour
later that the writers actually breached
the building do you think she's an hour
later do you think she's being honest
but had her timeline wrong no that makes
no sense how is she being honest she so
so that would mean that if she was being
honest she was in her office the cop
knocked on her door and then she had a
psychic premonition of people raiding
the capitol
they're going to raid the capital and
they might be here now right she was no
longer
no one knew that was gonna happen she
lied made the whole thing up and and
i've been to the capitol building i've
been to the halls of congress it it's
difficult to figure that that building
out to go through the tunnel it's very
difficult
of course we have to get escorted and
they showed us how to get down there and
if you were down there for the first
time you don't know where it goes you
don't know where to go where door to go
out to is is real it's a big uh hallway
in the middle where they got trains and
stuff going through there and so it's
like come on man i mean she she is a
liar it's the same thing people the left
does this well and the reason why is age
youth
she
is in the era of social media
republicans don't have a lot of young
people involved and therefore they are
not capturing the social media you know
frenzy and they're not getting the reach
that aoc is getting if you notice it's
the older people that don't even use
facebook i mean some of the people some
of the republicans probably don't even
know how to use social media at this
point they're not good at it that's why
we are let's say we i'm a republican
that's why we should get younger people
involved like marjorie um i think it's
marjorie margie marjorie
right she's younger in the 30 40 range
she's not 60 50 60. she's healthy
i hear you're saying but it is kind of
scary that
there's she's the old that she's the
young one
right i mean how do she gonna beat you
up next time she sees it no
i'm just messing with you no we gotta we
gotta be real i guess i was like i don't
wanna call her old or anything like that
because she's only 47. but uh uh that
it's kind of crazy that
we need millennials because we don't
have term limits we need term limits
because otherwise you're going to get
all these 80 year olds it's not cool
though politics are not cool you can run
for office when you're 75 for the first
time i feel like i feel like trump made
it a little more cool you know a little
more dynamic you don't have to be a
politician to be in office so but it's
not sexy to be a politician it's but
people need to make it that way and i
feel like i feel like aoc for the left
she made it cool the kennedy
assassination made it not cool for me
like i can't get in there and speak my
mind because i'm afraid that they're all
watching me and they know where i sleep
like that's i'm not comfortable with
that if a president gets in there they
really want to change the system they're
going to need to duck out of the country
for a while because the cia is not going
to like it this system is like in place
for a reason
yes scary i know politics can twist it
open i don't but when you're young i
mean most people that probably should be
in politics don't desire to be in
politics right and the people that do
desire beating politics are people
probably who are power hungry and
narcissistic and that's how they end up
getting in paradise and they get power
and they love it sociopaths yeah and so
it's unfortunate but like
i don't know how to fix it but younger
people need to feel more confident that
look this is our country
it's yeah it needs a bunch of things
have to happen at once we need young new
intelligent politicians we need new
pieces of technology and new shows that
are being developed that are like
invigorating the entire process but it
has to happen all at once it can't be
one or the other right i'm just not the
person that can get into politics
because of my mind state that's too
dangerous for me thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 p.m and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time
you